and you factor if your condom splits
two percent of the time
probably i don't know
he's about to it's a question
it's a question he's seeking legal
advice in his mind right now
because the product didn't work right
yeah but then again she's still got the
choice whether or not she wants to kiss
more times of people having babies it's
because they're not using condoms so
even your argument doesn't matter
because you didn't have you didn't use a
condom you weren't using condoms
so it doesn't matter that's
but okay incorrect
okay
one off okay but you're telling me men
have multiple children and every single
child was the two percent like
comfortable no that's no that's nothing
you're saying i'll say i'll tell you one
thing the story you told about the
golden essay i actually understand what
you're saying because i was in a similar
situation like i understand what you're
saying however
more times that's not the situation and
people are just reckless people out here
just spreading their seed everywhere
thinking nothing's gonna happen
there's consequences to actions if
you're deciding to be sexually
promiscuous as a man there's
consequences so take precautions that's
the point yeah but i i get that well you
don't because you're arguing against it
i'm not arguing against it yes you are
what have you been doing bro i am saying
to you you sounded like you like the
sound of your own no no no no no no no
please if someone understands listen i'm
saying to you guys this yeah
if i have sex with a woman and i have a
condom on it's not a hundred percent
right yes it's not but it's a bonus
sorry
it's not 100
right right we know it's not 100 but
okay let's go with that it's 100
yeah if i had sex with you that means
you don't have you don't have a child
okay
now
if i choose to have sex with you without
a condom does that mean i am saying that
i i am agreeing to have a child with you
you're both reckless
forget about reckless not going to say
you can't forget about reckless because
you are being reckless and that's the
thing that might make you get pregnant
so are you being reckless what do you
mean you're both are you like no we're
not are you being reckless
if a girl is not requiring men to put on
a condom before if before they have sex
she is also being reckless but what i'm
saying is if you keep getting different
[ __ ] pregnant the common denominator
is you
yes you if you keep finding yourself in
the same situation you may be the
problem
it's like it's like future coming here
just like just like if the girl has
multiple baby daddies it might be her
yeah exactly it might be her it's like
it's my future coming here and saying
it's not my fault i've seen it i don't
agree
okay if i have casual sex casual oh my
god i do not want to have a kid i want
to have a sense
talking for me i'm not talking for me
just for me bro i'm talking about men
i'm talking about men in general
and their ability to have casual sex
that's why
because two percent is a large
proportion of people
that's why i said that you said when you
said
we finished you said you said the small
percentage just doesn't matter and i'm
saying two percent of a large proportion
of people is a lot of people
a lot of men that have to go through
that
and there's no r there's no recourse for
it it's just that you was irresponsible
they're not they're not there's no
recourse for what
like i don't i just don't understand
what point you're making
like like i think you still have casual
six without being a girlfriend can we
can we agree that if you keep getting
women pregnant it it might be your fault
right it might be your fault yes or no
yes
can we agree that if you're a woman that
keeps getting pregnant for other men and
you have multiple baby for baby fathers
it might be your fault
can we agree that most men no that get
because she
she chooses who her baby father is no we
said it's her fault yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah can we agree that most men
can we agree that most men that are
getting girls pregnant left and right
are not wearing contraception
most yes yes
okay
so we agree okay can i just say can i
just say one point
we're not disagreeing with one point two
percent okay
if you order two percent and you've done
everything right and the condom still
rips unfortunately that's life
see now we're answering my question
see now we're getting that's my question
now you see now you're answering it and
that is fake bro you can't how is that i
mean fake excited you just said you said
i'm irresponsible if i don't use a
condom you are oh wait
hold on but you're irresponsible if i
don't use a condom but if i use one it's
tough luck if it breaks what else am i
going to say to you
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry life is hard
because actions have consequences and if
you if you don't choose to get married
some guys choose to get married young so
they don't have to deal with this [ __ ]
if you want to be in the streets there's
consequences for being in the streets
this isn't controversial let me say
something if you if your condom breaks
yeah you better have good negotiation
skills that's what i'm saying
and wasn't your original just have good
negotiation skills the original anecdote
was if you're married right with a child
and then you go sleep with someone and
then get them pregnant on the first time
literally wrap your dick up or just be
faithful to your woman it's really not
that hard
thank you yeah it sounded like someone
oh girl sometimes
did we get did we get any super chats
practice abstinence that's the best ways
and if you want to have children
abstinence
or just be careful man it's not hard
check who you have sex with and do your
part so that it mitigates the
the chance of that happening it's that
simple i'm glad we feel there's so many
men out black men out here not having
kids i hate when you say oh black men
have this problem no
no none of my friends have this problem
do you know what i think we're done i
think we found a female chess girl
i think we just found female jessica no
no
no way there was just a
misinterpretation of what i meant i'm
talking about the two percent guys i'm
not saying i'm not saying that they're
not the majority i'm talking about the
two percent guys here where the condom
is burst
are we saying that it's tough luck for
you lot even though women have six
different contraceptions that they could
use to stop you even though you knew i
just wanted to have casual sex would you
write dreams
because you knew you knew all this stuff
for all these facts before you had sex
you knew that dude so that's why it's
tough luck because unfortunately you
took every precaution there's nothing
you could do and it ripped that's life
do you drive i drive right ninety i've
never had an accident in my car right
but it's possible that i could
right so 99 of the time that i'm driving
on the road i don't have an accident if
i have an accident people say
she couldn't see that coming i never saw
it coming that person maybe never saw it
coming but it's part of life
so it's it
it actually [ __ ] what do they say [ __ ]
happens bro okay so single player but
the thing is but if i say oh um
i should i could say i'm never gonna
drive
i could stop driving and say the reason
people can ask me why don't you drive
because there's a two percent chance i
could have an accident and you can still
be here by call even if you don't drive
i mean i mean i i agree i agree you
might actually just not have sex bro
you know that two percent is there
just like i know the two percent of
having an accident on the street i can
say i'm not going to drive but i drive
yeah also also me personally i've never
smoked my life i've never done a drug
overdone other than drink alcohol just
like i've never done anything like that
but i could still get cancer i can still
get cancer right it's life it's not
basically it's just casual sex and women
could have casually if that's if that's
what you take from it then fair enough
though
protect yourself we established it then
protect yourself have as much
intercourse as you want ladies do
whatever you want as much as much as you
want you know it's crazy it makes sense
like why do you why do you like this
this is what i'm sorry you argue like a
girl because this is what girls do is
when they say i said things that i
didn't say i advocate all the time that
women shouldn't sleep around i know
you're just
for no reason that's why no one said
that like wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait i
said i said
there's a great um
you're allowed to sleep around no no i
did not say that you were allowed to
sleep around i don't know what i'm
saying i'm saying i'm saying you're
allowed to sleep around who is allowed
to sleep around anyone that wants to
sleep around is allowed to sleep around
i'm just saying there are consequences
that go with it 100
that's that's my standpoint like you
know i mean you're allowed to do
whatever you want but it doesn't mean
you have to be doing it with me
i mean
okay so it's not foolproof you know
condoms aren't foolproof you are
choosing to have sex with another person
so what comes with that is also the
understanding that the other person can
make a decision that's going to impact
your life which is why you have to vet
the person why should you have the
responsibility because it's your life
let her engage go on why should why
should why should you why should you be
responsible
why should the men be responsible i'm
saying you can take every precaution but
you still have to be mature enough to
understand that by having sex with this
person pregnancy is a possibility yes
right so if something does go wrong
you might have to live with that
consequence correct yes
okay so know the person you're sleeping
with
don't don't have unprotected sex take
every precaution but if that happens and
the woman doesn't want to abort at the
end of the day you made that decision
you had ever you had so many chances
before you could have picked a different
woman there are so many other things you
could do instead of just blaming the
woman that doesn't want to kill a baby
like that
and i just don't understand why also
also
there's so many goals sorry sorry about
it there's so many people who have sex
with girls who you can tell even if she
says she takes a pill you can tell that
she's not exactly someone who keeps to a
schedule so she might miss a day or two
every now and then and you'll still have
sex and be like oh she's linked she's
like let me just do it that's your fault
you picked her you picked her you can do
everything you can you can use a condom
and still pull out and if you get if she
gets pregnant that's life so if it's